this is an exclusive my talk of the
table is a cbs mornings only exclusive
right here right now the 2022 time 100
list is out today the magazine's annual
list of the 100 most influential people
in the world we are the first to show
you some of these powerful influencers
who made the time 100 cover actress
zendaya we all know her we love her of
course multi grammy winner mary j blige
harry and apple ceo tim cook and shang
chi actor simulu made the list as well
so did the prime minister of barbados
near mali i love this because
influence influence regardless of your
walk of life your profession whatever
you do you have some significant
influence on the world in time magazine
they love to honor those individuals all
the names we saw there we're not
surprised that zendaya's on it mary jay
is on it and that tim cook is on it i
can't wait to go
to the list and we we have we have the
list that we just showed and they have
positive influence on the world it's one
thing to have the stage using it
properly is